I think the hardest thing about having
to cancel the head above water World
Tour because we had it Europe China
Japan in Southeast Asia and had to
cancel the hardest part about that was
that I had like just overcome Lyme
disease in my own personal health battle
just got back out there with my album
head above water and was doing this tour
so it was such a bummer because I've
waited so long and started the fans but
you know we have to all dark heart and
keep everybody safe
gotta keep my
[Music]
being at home a lot of people are coping
in different ways
and you just said now you know you had
all this energy and momentum are you
able to channel it into other artistic
endeavors are you writing more are you
playing more music at home like how
what's going on with that I've been
writing a lot of songs um I have a
studio in my house so that's nice one of
the songs she's recently recorded at
home is a new take on a 2019 single
warrior the new version is called we are
warriors dedicated to those in the front
lines of the Koba 19 pandemic
[Applause]
[Music]
all proceeds from the single will be
going to Project Hope which helps
provide personal protective equipment to
health care workers around the world I
just wanted to put the song out to
motivate to lift people up and then ends
he also just to motive
they then to to keep up the fight
against Co fit 19 I'm just doing my part
want to flatten the curb stay at home
you know stay safe keep everybody safe
and just you know be responsible about
the whole thing and then the meantime
you know turn to music and I hope that
estar just like um looks people up and
lifts their spirits up yeah is there
anything that you wanted to say
specifically to the frontline workers I
mean you believe in them so much and you
want to inspire them and support them at
this time
what do you want to say to them and also
to your fans that are struggling right
now I would like to say that the
frontline workers just a huge thank you
and then it's like I'm so in awe of like
how you guys are all coming together and
thank you so much and you guys are the
true heroes you are all warriors who
we're all boards together even just by
staying in and staying home and everyone
having to put everything on hold to do
the right thing